grace
how are you feeling right now because
obviously you can't stand boris johnson
are you presumably i don't feel that
much better about most members of the
conservative party to be honest and i
think what tom was just saying is it's
interesting and it's true you know i am
not 100 sure which way it will go it
obviously does seem very close perhaps
closer than we would have thought
earlier in the day um but
two weeks ago i think it was you and i
were sitting in the studio we were
discussing the su grey report um and
i think you asked me whether or not i
thought the boris johnson was going to
go and i said
he should go but i don't think that he
will go you know i don't think that he
really knows what accountability means i
think that he basically has been you
know spent his career in environments
where he's been able to get through
anything well if he loses he loses
tonight and it's interesting only 157 or
so tory mps have publicly declared their
support that's at least 20 fewer than at
the same stage with theresa may so
whether that's significant or not we
don't know we can't really trust them
all um but
that is a pretty worrying indicator i
would say if you're if you're attending
downing street tonight yeah and what
thomas is saying about how there's no
clear leader in place is a really
important point and what kate was saying
about how most of these npc their
relationship with boris johnson is
transactional obviously that's true for
you know most any mp generally and their
political leader the issue is that
transaction goes both ways you know yes
um you know they need boris johnson and
boris johnson also needs them the
question that they have to then be
asking is what's going to happen when
boris johnson goes and as of the last
election the conservative party has been
in this state of you know division
basically between a group of mps who
believe it's their job to fight for the
soul of the conservative party as this
kind of free market small state
austerity driven project and those who
think oh actually we need to kind of
lose a little bit of that and go back to
you know perhaps some more investment
get rid of all this austerity baggage
and fight lots of culture wars in order
to broaden our coalition those two
groups are going to go at each other in
a very very fierce way regardless of
what happens in this country i mean we
saw it today isabel was nadine doris
immediately getting into a massive
public spat with jeremy hunt raising
some good points i have to say in her
tweet storm about his own record as
health secretary in failing to prepare
the country properly for a pandemic
but it was open civil war erupting on
social media right at the heart of the
conservative party this is going to be
the problem whoever tries to take over
you've got to somehow bring all these
factions together and you've got to
still maintain the remain
leave kind of you know
cliques that are going on it's not easy
you've got a rece potential recession
certainly surging inflation to deal with
this is this is a bit of a hospital pass
it almost always is though isn't it i
mean you mentioned the brexit thing
which we all wish that we'd kind of left
behind but you're absolutely right that
is now going to become a real problem
you know we've already seen one of boris
johnson's greatest critics tobias elwood
runs the defense select committee
reopening the question of whether or not
the uk should rejoin the single market
now i thought his timing on that was a
little bit dangerous given his agenda is
to remove boris don't now bring in the
brexit thing because it allows downing
street right to try to argue that you
know this is all a big plot to unravel
brexit uh jeremy hunt one of the key
rebels also a big remainer and i think
that will annoyingly for everybody who
just wishes that we you know this
question had been resolved and parked
this is all going to bubble up again
yeah sharon
what do you make of this because at the
heart of it really is boris johnson and
his staff at downing street going
partying breaking brazenly their own
laws which everybody else had to follow
and the reason i think it's cut through
so powerfully with the public is that so
many of them were not allowed to go and
see dying relatives in hospital i know i
know people including some in my family
who couldn't go and see
people as they died from covered in
hospitals and then to find out the
people making these laws were basically
on the lash everywhere well it was like
caligula at number 10.
uh you know puking throwing wine up the
wall god only knows what was going on
but the thing is
he lied
he lied he lied and surely somebody in
his position knows it will truth will
always come out no matter how long it
takes it always comes out and you look
worse so own it that was his big big
business
he's just done it boris is he's lied
through his entire career as a
journalist and politician and he's
always seemed to fail upwards so he got
fired from the times for inventing
quotes he got fired you know under
michael howard for lying about an affair
and each time he's saying become london
mayor and then he's become prime
minister so the message he gets to
himself is actually lying doesn't matter
and i think that's what's brought him
down that's the past and the thing is
yes he's quirky and he's this funny
little character that
england loved for a while you know he's
this funny little guy but the thing is
the guy has no vision
what's what's the vision of the
conservative party where is it going
does he have anything
also called the old fashioned country
right but don't we also want integrity
in our prime minister of course we do
but that come on we're living in the
real world here everybody is too much to
ask yes everybody lies everybody does
what they have to do for power power we
all know what goes on
behind the doors but the thing is
what the situation that this country is
in right now do you take the devil you
know or the devil you don't know look
he's not going to laugh
i would keep that nutter in
no i would i would keep him in the sand
i would keep him in until there's a
long-term plan for this country what are
they going to do about the economy what
are they going to do the issue is the
issue i think is once once trust is
broken with the british people
very hard to then trust that person i'd
use him
to tell us how he's going to rescue the
country if i was a conservative mp i
would keep him in as well and the thing
that i would be thinking as a
conservative mp would be let boris fight
the next election probably lose okay it
will be a hung parliament it won't be
there won't be a kind of stable
government for particularly long the
conservative party get their brief
period out of office they get to sort
their stuff out they're going to find
the leader and they get to decide what
they're doing let's take another look